should you be shooting like a wrestle
development and being Batman and stuff
well we are shooting we've been shooting
arrest the bellman we're almost finished
and I've been saying that since about
2005 okay and we're finishing up the
fifth season Arrested Development and
it's been really really fun and that's
that's been going on for a few months
and but I took a little break and I've
come up here to visit some family and
also come up here to mad crush which is
a restaurant run by Jamison Kerr and was
an old friend of mine and also a
business partner I have an interest in
this restaurant and a few other
restaurants and it's been really a
fantastic fun experience for me yeah it
was part of the appeal of it that it was
here in Toronto your hometown good old
friend that kind of thing 100%
I know Toronto and I you know it just
felt like something good that felt
really right while we are gearing up for
award season one snub we couldn't help
but notice critically-acclaimed
Lego Batman was left out of the Best
Animated Feature khattak what are your
feelings on this because in the office
we all think you know this was an
oversight
raiga it would have been great for the
film to be recognized Chris McKay who
directed it it's an amazing job this is
not a knock to other movies that are
nominated that's neither here nor there
and just it would have been nice if we
had been recognized for sure yeah you
know but at the end of the day also who
cares you know award it's also
unbelievably subjective and there's so
much other stuff and playing politics
well I mean with your turn and Lego
Batman
some might say you're arguably the
greatest Batman of our time I that would
be a tough position to defend but okay
yeah well we a lot of us like I'm
excited for the Teen Titans go
yes movies all of us have kids and other
kids inside are excited for the sto well
you view reprising Batman in this film I
will not but there's a great person
someone whom we all love and enjoy who I
asked to be Batman in the film okay and
he's gonna do a great job Batman doesn't
figure as prominently in it and because
it's not like Oh Batman we thought it
would be more fun for this guy to play
Batman I play Slade who is the bad guy
Oh Slade we see you on Twitter a lot on
social media a lot and one of your
favorite topics is a I think it sounds
like him makes me sound like a loser you
are a busy man so I don't know how you
have all the time but what's funny is
like you've got a great point of view
about and sense of humor about evidence
going on in American politics what's
your favorite front moment of the last
and no that's same 45 days or so we were
talking a little bit earlier about that
the hair thing that everything was
interesting I don't get it yeah I'm kind
of stymied by it I want to see it up
close you want to get in you want to get
into the White House
no no I want to make it a big deal yeah
I want to come in with cameras you guys
can come great we'll do it together
it was like let's get in just take a
look it's just what you need another
project yeah
thing else to be involved I do I do i
because i have like two weeks available
in june and it might be great to fill it
yeah that you're not gonna visit your
mom that I'm not gonna visit my mom or
be here yeah
also I'm I might do guest chef ding oh
don't come then what if I do not come if
I'm a - effing okay no they call it
cheffing anymore I don't know if that's
an official forever it's changed yeah a
lot has changed